Did Bill Skarsgard creep you out?
Does he creep you out on the set
when he's playing Pennywise?
Well, I'm really tough,
so I was unprepared,
'cause I thought I could
kinda handle anything,
and then we were at the table read,
and he was sitting where you are,
actually, this was the same configuration,
and we're reading, and
then all of a sudden,
everyone's normal,
everyone's acting normal
and not weird, and then all of a sudden,
Bill starts saying his character,
and he just turned to me,
and screamed in my face, "Boo!"
You know, like that weird voice he gets?
Yeah.
And I yelled like I was six years old.
(crowd laughing)
In front of everyone, in front of
all the executives at Warner Brothers,
and it was so embarrassing.
They all went like this, "Yes!"
Yeah!
(crowd laughs)
He's still got it!
We shall profit from this!
(laughter)
We still have our Pennywise!
Pennywise still has it!
Yes!
(laughter)
Tell the others to go home!
They had nine replacements lined up, yeah.
Aw, damn!
James were you creeped
out by his performance?
Or did he enter your dreams
after making this movie?
(laughter)
I'm just generally creeped out by clowns
but I read the book when I was a kid
and it didn't scare me, I seem to remember
but as an adult reading it again,
I definitely had Pennywise in my thoughts
and I definitely had Bell in my thoughts.
I remember one dream that I had
where I was lying on my side in bed
and he was behind me stroking my back.
Oh!
(crowd laughs)
And he was saying hey, baby wake up.
but I guess it was like,
hey, bay be wake up, whoo.
(crowd laughs)
Is it possible that,
that was Bill Skargard?
(crowd and cast laughs)
Maybe, but I.
He's done that to me and yeah.
How'd you get into my summer home?
You just have to pretend to be asleep.
(Conan laughs)
Which we've all done.